and a new hashtag campaign is
encouraging people to unplug from the
online world jomo is short for the joy
of missing out the concept was designed
to take the familiar FOMO fear of
missing out and turn it on its head 26
percent of American adults say they are
almost always online that actually seems
low to me forty-five percent of US
teenagers also say they're always online
and research says when you spend that
much time online it can make you less
happy and more disconnected with the
world CBS Sunday morning contributor
David Pogue is with us in the new year
so news about David he'll return to the
New York Times writing for the smarter
living Section David good morning good
morning
living smartly these days involves not
living online it sounds like that's
right well you've heard of FOMO this is
when all the shoulds I should go to that
party even though I feel like staying
home all of us made much worse of course
by the smartphone because you're
spending your time immersed in Facebook
and Instagram seeing everybody else's
shiny happy lives that you feel like you
should be living jomo the joy of missing
out is you know when you discover the
plane doesn't have Wi-Fi so you're off
the hook don't worry
after freaking out discover the joy
that's right that secret joy when if
somebody cancels something you were
supposed to go to you know you're
quietly happy about it that's Jomo so
that the tech companies are getting
ahead of some criticism here it sounds
like they're kind of understanding that
people don't really like being chained
to their phones and they're saying look
we get it we get it why don't we take a
break have some space that's right this
was kind of like the year of the digital
well being Apple and Android from Google
and Facebook Instagram have all
introduced features that put in your
face how much time you're spending on
your phone how many times a day you wake
it that will horrify right it's in the
hundreds it has and lets you put limits
on it to help you sort of realize just
how in deep you are it's actually helped
me now I look at this screen time
feature on my phone and it tells me how
many hours a day I'm on my phone I okay
I'll admit it four to five hours a day
on I know but a lot of that is research
it breaks it down for you yeah why
research on about instant work my friend
why would tech companies be doing this
you know they want people to use their
product yeah it seems counterintuitive
like we're gonna try to get you to use
our products less I can think of two
reasons one is you know they say they
really care about you they really don't
want you to be addicted but the other
reason is big tech has a bad name these
days they're they're getting into more
and more trouble I think they'd rather
say look how proactive were being
voluntarily addressing the problem
before some government school parents
takes the control away from them I was
fascinated to see that the service
industry is sort of getting involved
like Windham hotels offers you a
discount if you lock up your phone why
would they go to these extremes do
that's true they'll give you five
percent off your bill and because you
won't have your camera with you they
give you a portable polaroid camera to
carry around
well three reasons what one is they
really do want you to come back right
they want you to have a good time they
don't want you to go home as stressed as
when you came right so that's one reason
another is they have actual logistical
problems Windham says the average family
showing up at a stay has 12 Wi-Fi
devices I don't believe that you're
clogging the hotel's Wi-Fi networks
they're cluttering the lobby with people
honey I'm just gonna make a phone call
in the lobby they're filling up the pool
chairs by not going into the water but
just sitting out beside it so help
people help themselves what you have for
folks who need to unplug and be in the
moment well first thing is do you have a
problem and that's kind of easy to you
know if if you're still looking at the
pictures of an event while it's going on
you have a problem if you can't imagine
going without your phone for a day
that's that's a problem
if you feel phantom vibrations in your
pockets you you think you're getting a
notification vibration but it's not
really happening and then the next thing
is to turn on these features screen time
it's in settings on the iPhone and
digital well being is Google's app
equivalent app for Android try them out
and you may discover that wow you could
do better
you can also make rules I'm not going to
use this at the table and if that all
goes well and you do feel a little jomo
then that'll be an improvement in your
unless of course you have fo Jomo that's
the fear of the joy I would say it's
almost like that idea of will we go too
far
ya know GOG we are hooked on his Damon
Pope thank you very much